on
va faire une interview mensonge
[Musique]
tu connais tu veux le principe doit
mentir voilà c'est pas compliqué comment
ça va co et
bella écoute ça va super bien
tu es content d'être ici ce soir enfin
franchement je me fais chier grave et ça
me saoule de sa c2 sait quel âge
maintenant écoute un bon 22 ouais là les
volets demain tagro si un peu non
d'abord ça me fait très plaisir ce que
tu me dis et non je pense que j'ai pas
mal mais grid 1 ou 2 kg 1 ouais tu dois
beaucoup à bataille et fontaine
que dalle
je trouve que ce sont des gros cons tu
es fier de travailler avec eux
écoute je vomis chaque matin mais
beaucoup un jeu fruit beaucoup beaucoup
tu arriveras pas me faire dire des
saloperies
que tf1 ça se passe bien écoutons se
défoncer la gueule tous les matins tous
les matins on s'insultait tout avec les
patrons de tf1 c'est une affaire
d'amitié avant tout non non c'est une
affaire de coucheries c'est parce que je
suis le fils d diène et il ya eu des
rapports plus haut entre nous la méthode
cauet tu trouve ça original comme
concept et en chine mais je trouve que
je t'ai tour pompe et
ça c'est pas l'interview - son nez si
non tu as ton carnet de chèque de pierre
bordés d'ailleurs une nouvelle double
pour les interviews philippe les poutres
parce que je voudrais tenir le reste du
décor est la mienne vous pouvez la fin
de l'année je te donne
pas sa dépouille et colonnes jamais les
colonnes corinthiennes j'appelle ça des
poutres le coup il n'a pas dit qu'il
était avant la crise et en même temps
dis moi il ya quand même des interviews
un peu qui ressemble un peu à celle de
tout le monde en parle des fois écoute
franchement non jamais oh oui
je suis très content j'ai un avantage je
n'arrive même pas à le suivre quand même
tu comment pour essayer de lui le
meilleur animateur de la tête par contre
c'est maintenant le dire mais c'est vrai
que je suis mauvais ouais bon c'est vrai
il est édenté sartine bloch lainé cette
griffe comme jamais une interview qui
ressemble aux miennes départ et tu as
remarqué que je t'ai jamais fait de
scandale à toi suite envoyé une lettre
où une fois mais après j'ai abandonné
bon we meet avait tout mis dedans tu as
les pendouiller 2
et il avait dit que je répond péter
hauteur et qui avait des trucs dans ton
émission qui était dans la mienne voilà
c'est plutôt des trucs dans ton émission
culte mais j'ai pas j'ai pas su quoi
répondre et d'ailleurs ce que je
comprends bien non parce qu'on m'a
envoyé un chèque je côtoie maintenant on
n'est pas ce que parce que d'abord tu as
peut-être paf tu as peut-être pas tort
vu que tu fais de la tête non mais t'as
vu que tu fais de la télé depuis avant
moi vu que georgette pas cité de date
mais vu que quand j'étais petit je te
regarde et ça c'est déjà mais que joue
vraiment que j'étais fan ça mais je ne
manque plus que j'étais fan lunettes par
pour nuits blanches que j'aime et double
je vois bien à l'antenne on voit bien là
qu'on n'a pas été nombreux à aimer mais
moi j'aime et et les zèbres alors il ya
un truc que je comprends pas a me dit
était de chez daphné roulier tu m'as pas
cité une seule fois et des chemises
jaunes poule parce que si je si c'est
parce que si je cite tout le monde ça
fait lèche cul donc parce que j'ai cités
qui j'ai cité foucault un statut et
admirait beaucoup déjà été trompé la
pâte les chaînes américaines
mais
mr
sébastien mais en plus tu sais que tu me
pique mes idées mais j'existe mais je te
piquent pas tes idées je trouve juste
que je franchement je vous jure que
c'est vrai
franchement quand on fait un hommage
chaque semaine à thierry ardisson non
mais franchement stupide tous je n'ai
pas répondu à ta lettre mais je te jure
qu'on t'a rien impliqué d'accord je te
promets que si j'enlève les arguments
sont là je te les rendrait ici je te les
amène je te jure d'accord fait le studio
de la méthode cauet je te prends le pari
si je viens tu as mené les colonnes donc
on enlève derrière mais est-ce que moi
perso j'en peux plus si toi tu aimes
bien vachement faible ou j'adore donc je
te les ramène riche d'imagés quelles
sont les émissions que tu regardes en ce
moment pas beaucoup
je dois te regarde et toi
c'est obligé en même temps non assise
pour trouver des idées
non
non non
ouais il paraît que tu es un grand b
heures c'est vrai
écoute non
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu